Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness. Today is day 37.
We're talking about emotions. Now, emotions, feelings, are
great and horrible. They're part of what makes us human,
right? And we can either figure out how to fight them or how to
recruit them to help in the project of holiness of heart and
holiness of life that God is calling you to.
So please, don't fight them. All right? Don't deny them.
At one point in my life, I made the mistake of thinking that I needed to be
this emotionless Christian, melancholy, and it was
terrible.
And I didn't please God. I'm sure I didn't please God as much as I should have
during that season, because God is pleased when we are emotionally happy
in Him. But sometimes people do make a mistake that makes their feelings their
enemy of holiness instead of their friend.
So I want to talk to you about that today.
Frequently, a mistake that a lot of people make is
connecting holiness so closely to their
emotions that they feel as though their holiness
rises and falls based on how they're feeling.
How holy they're feeling, how excited they're feeling, how confident they're
feeling, how saved they're feeling.
People often do the same thing with marriage.
We think that love is a feeling, an emotion, and
we start dating, and we feel warm fuzzies, and we assume that's what love is.
But then we wake up next to that same person six years later,
and they have bad breath, and their hair is a mess, and
we have a headache, and we're not feeling good, and we're feeling grumpy that day,
and we think,
"Where did the love go?"
Well, love isn't a feeling. It might cause feelings, and those feelings
may come, and they may go, but love itself is not a feeling.
It is a commitment, an action, a commitment to act in the
best interest of the other person.
And you need to sustain your relationship with your spouse by
commitment, not feelings. And do two things to your emotions.
Cultivate them and enjoy them.
Your feelings did not create your marriage, and they cannot
destroy your marriage. Your feelings do not create your
holiness, and they cannot destroy your holiness.
You are not saved, you are not made holy by feeling good about God
or yourself. Instead, you should reaffirm your
commitment to the Lord when your emotions are down, and then cultivate the
environment, the mindset, where the right emotions
are possible. And this makes your emotions your
friend, the friend of your holiness, instead of the enemy of it.
Instead of fighting against me doing right and doing the will of God
and living like Jesus and having His mind and His heart.
Instead of
being the enemy of that, instead it becomes a support.
It becomes a tailwind that pushes me further
in my pursuit of God because I am glad in Him,
and I'm joyful in Him.
Now, tomorrow, we're going to talk about exactly
how. I'm going to talk about some of the techniques, some of the ways to
cultivate those emotions. But I just want to tell you for
today, they can be your friend or your enemy. Don't deny them.
Don't squash them. Don't consider them your enemy.
Instead, find ways to recruit them so that they are your friend.
Just find ways to cultivate the right emotions and make them possible,
and then enjoy them, and let them drive you further down the
road on the project, and the following of holiness.
We'll talk to you tomorrow.